they have the kid they are a lot older
right but they don't re they don't
they're not very cognizant of the fact
that once you had a child and you got
married your life has now changed yes
and so they they want to be a part of
your non-kid life but they don't know
how to right yeah so I had you know I'm
in that age now where my friends are now
having kids and so you know I'll go do
things and they go oh let's go do some
[__] together too yeah and they're like
okay like oh can like my wife and kids
come I'm like you're not coming and
they're like oh why not I'm like this is
not a wife and kids type trip in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast I forgot my personal
cameras so if you're watching this on
the video side not only that no I didn't
forget the cameras I forgot the SD cards
and the lenses which apparently forgot
your life bro yeah you left it in Big
Bear which is a very very important so
we're just shooting it on the regular
camera which is you know perfectly fine
but I prefer the way that I I shoot
things well but whatever man we just got
back from Big Bear yes sir fun little
trip it was nice yeah it's your little
uh Bachelor trip dude when we had that
you know it was essentially the original
uh K-Town crew yeah yeah except we're
much older dog when I looked at the the
group photo that we had all I saw is
like a bunch of [__] auditions that's
what we are though we're middle-aged now
you know we're [__] mid-30s dude yeah
well speak for yourself [__] I'm almost
40 man
that's [__] great time goes by so
fast yeah yeah I was looking at that
photo yeah and I started cracking up
because
you know we were talking about at the
trip like when we're when you're in your
mid-20s yeah you care about so many
different things right and then as you
get older you care less and less and
less I'm at the point where I care about
it almost absolutely nothing yeah it's
priorities right I mean as you go
through life you start to recognize the
things that improve your quality of life
versus take away from it yeah and you
just focus on the things that you know
improve your quality of life or keep it
at a good place I just feel like now
certain things just don't matter anymore
like you said you know I saw this uh
like a couple of photos like a couple
months back where a couple of pongzangs
they went to
um not Big Bear but Tahoe and they're
like dressed in like the nicest clothes
ever and they're at a cabin trip in the
[__] Forest yeah and they got you
know whatever the [__] nicest shirts
they're [__] sneakers and everything
else yeah they got their [__]
expensive shades on they made sure to
get a haircut before they went to the
cabin they're posing and [__] I'm like
you [__] ass give give yourself of six
years and I want to see if you look like
that at a [__] cabin trip hey you
know what though granted also too I came
up and Street closed the the first day
when you guys were already on the boat
and so I was definitely overdressed I
felt like for for the occasions
everybody else I mean you're definitely
one of the more fashionable ones like
there's a couple of people in the group
who have never been factual from the
date from the jump so it doesn't matter
you know what I mean so we weren't
expecting anything else anyways I looked
decrepit like when I when I showed up
on TV
dude
so big bear is pretty crazy if you guys
haven't been there I I mean I've been
there a couple of times but I I think
just because the weather this whole year
has been [__] nuts yeah bipolar as
[__] man yeah so it rained in L.A again
in September which never [__] happens
right we had the the quote unquote
tropical storm that happened and this
time on his way up it was terrible bro
like or so we were coming up guys and we
had pouring rain for like five minutes
it would stop clear up start sprinkling
clear up Rain a little bit clear up fog
hits in clears up can't see anything
like three feet visibility clears up so
we're coming up the mountain and these
guys are already up there so we're like
yo we're boating in this weather like
that sounds like a recipe for disaster
and then once we get up to the you know
peak elevation it's like yeah it's sunny
we're like what the [__] it was weird it
was like cold rainy hot cold really hot
but the second day that we were there it
was it was pretty [__] yeah oh that
was that was our last full day there
right I think so yeah yeah yeah and it
was it was pretty much ideal [__] way
yeah it was it was absolutely beautiful
yeah but when you know what we're doing
this like big bear trip this is like
technically like a quote-unquote
bachelor party I've been married for two
years now but so it's not like the
bachelor party that most people think
where you know you get strippers and
whatever whatnot yeah I don't really
care for that that's not my stage in
life right now so that's what we're
saying on the record
we just went into a cab and just chilled
and kick in we got a really big spot
ahead like a pool table foosball table
movie room and everybody kind of just
got to do what they wanted to do and
just chill the [__] out yeah and then we
kind of saw like when I was looking at
this photo like I said earlier like I
really don't give a [__]
just looking at the photos of me just
made me laugh because I'm picturing my
younger 20 year old self and now right
and this 20 year old self never
understood why like my dad suddenly had
this weird departure from dressing the
way he did because I saw old photos of
it yeah he's styling yeah he was styling
like he looked really [__] good he
had the cool ass [__] aviators you
know the Slick little [__] jacket the
pants the high top sneaks and it was
when he was in his 30s like I I think if
it was in America at the time my brother
was just born so two years old so my dad
had to be about like 32-34 yeah 33-34 so
maybe like around the age I am now maybe
a year younger so about a year younger
yeah and he looked great yeah and then I
see him now Kirkland shoes yeah he
getting all tired bro life life set in
you know and I get it it's like you have
a kid you have all these things you're
married your life is set there's
absolutely nobody to impress what so
however yeah it doesn't [__] matter I
mean even look at our progression with
things like shoes for example right I
mean we still love Jays but we choose
not to put them on because we focus more
on practicality now right yeah of like
yo J's aren't comfortable I'd rather
have comfortable shoes on that look
decent yeah we could talk about that so
that's the other thing first of all as a
kid growing up not having a lot of money
I wanted every single J possible 100 and
I might have mentioned this before where
when I first started making a lot of
money I bought everything and anything I
wanted when I was a kid that I could not
afford same right yeah so when I was
younger like if we had stuff that we
couldn't afford either somebody had to
steal that [__] or we had a hustle to
get it right yep and you know when I
started making YouTube just to put it in
perspective when I first came to La I my
first YouTube check was like I think it
was like 500 bucks and I was like oh
[__]
baby yeah my rent was like 250 because
my cousin was uh paying for most of my
rent
so it was 250 for the room I kind of pay
that the other 250 was full which was
going to be Top Ramen or whatever right
but then those checks started growing
bigger it was like 500 to a thousand
three thousand five thousand seven
thousand ten thousand on and on
and then I remember I was like oh [__]
I'm buying [__] everything and these
are shoes that I never had like Jordan
11's I couldn't afford that [__] yeah a
few of my friends had nice sneakers
right I just never prioritized my money
on that stuff because I just wanted
other things and then I remember putting
on
um these Bred 11s that I always wanted
yes put it on my [__] feet and I was
like [__] man this [__] right here
[__] uncomfortable
that's so nice but so uncomfortable
there's no breathing on patent leather
yeah whatsoever I was like [__] and I
was fatter too so I had like Street
Fighter Street Fighter feet yeah
okay
yeah
[__] my people are fat as hell yeah and
I didn't care and I just [__]
squeezed my feet in that [__] yeah and I
just walked around on it and I remember
the first day that I was walking around
on it I wasn't trying to crease it so
I'm trying to walk all nice right but
then when I took it off I had blisters
on my feet and I'm like damn is this how
everybody feels yeah with their [__]
shoes and then I kept on and I was like
okay I'm getting the fives the fours the
threes the threes were probably the most
comfortable Jordan so if you guys don't
wear sneakers at all very wide base
fat shoe yeah right but basically goes
with absolutely anything and uh I
[__] love those and those were my
favorites and then I started going into
like the taxis and everything else and
my favorite shoe of all time is the
Jordan one and it is the most
uncomfortable shoe that has ever been
made in history yeah so I don't give a
[__] with anybody I love the way they
look no for sure but that's what I mean
is that like you know we still
appreciate it it's still like very
nostalgic in a part of our childhood but
it's like I don't want to spend even
half a day with those walking around you
know I got these Jordan I got the bread
ones I got the Chicago ones I got the
distressed ones I have
um
the the Travis Scott uh his version of
the mocha ones right and I just look at
them yeah because I know if I put that
in my feet I'm gonna bleed through those
[__] in two hours do they say man I
just have boxes in my closet you know I
mean I have
quite a bit of a collection of shoes I
would say like I don't know over 30
pairs at least yeah that that um I could
that I would still potentially wear
these days but how many I actually
rotate through I don't know maybe like
three four right yeah yeah it's hard man
like I look at them like I still have
them and this is what I did
I I told myself years ago after I went
through this whole phase of like buying
all the material possessions getting the
nice car whatever one I didn't do
anything for me so I said I'm gonna only
keep the shoes that I will potentially
wear and I sold like probably 70 of
myself oh yeah I remember I remember
when you're doing that yeah yeah I sold
all of that [__] right and I had some of
the shoes that I wanted since day one
since I was a kid yeah but you know a
lot of shoes that kind of dropped now
they're almost not wearable like they
look [__] ridiculous like Spaceman
boots and [__] I'll tell you this right
now if you go on YouTube as we speak and
you go on any YouTube short and you look
at the most popular sneaker heads and if
you don't fall in this category don't be
offended all right and if you do Jesus
Christ you are a [__] hideous the
clothes that you wear it's it's like
they wear these shoes right and it's
like this limited release I don't even
know the names I'm not into sneakers
that much anymore but it's like a
leather print here [__] neon green
here and all this other weird [__] and
like damn that [__] is hot like how much
you get that for look at what the [__]
you're wearing
why are sneaker heads literally the war
stressed human beings on Earth I mean
you know it's it's like a trend right
it's a trend sometimes maybe it sheds
light also on her age again it's just
that we're becoming that old man who are
like don't understand it anymore we're
getting disconnected I wouldn't say that
yeah
and I always think about that stuff too
and I think about that stuff when I
listen to music am I am I just being a
[__] old head or is this music just
really really bad I don't see for me
same I don't think so I just think that
music
sucks more than the music that we grew
up with I believe that some people might
not feel that way the younger
Generations might not feel that way but
when I listen to like you know like an
old record that comes on you know [__] I
don't know off the top of my head
earlier this morning I was listening to
like the Watcher part two it has a Dre J
and rock him right hip-hop Legends
when do you hear track like that these
days you know what I mean it's
like what the [__] is even saying right
now dude what is that yeah there's
definitely and a lot of people will
probably disagree if you're younger but
um there are younger generation rappers
that are dope that don't rap in the
style that we grew up with that I think
are [__] dope as [__] right
um but I think the you know problematic
for me is that when I listen to a lot of
Like Rappers now it's just I could take
any [__] kid off the block that
listens to your [__] they'll recite your
lyrics and they'll sound just as good or
even better than you yeah and I think
like that uniqueness sometimes has died
out and by the way in our generation too
we had a plenty of our own shitty
rappers for sure AKA Chingy like
one hit wonder he was [__] terrible
he was a terrible rapper yeah people
don't really say it out loud but in our
generation we had some trash ass [__]
rappers you know we had the the uh one
hit wonders Chingy was one of them I
don't know a single song besides Holiday
Inn no right there oh that said I like
them I can't do that right there was
that is that [__] hot lyrics and bars
absolutely [__] not he was not a very
good rapper but then he had Club bangers
and I see that a lot with other like
other younger rappers but yeah it's hard
for me to kind of like
um I don't know I just like I said if
they feel replaceable and that's in kind
of any genre nowadays too I I might get
[__] killed for this and I don't give
a [__] if you're a Swifty fan I don't
get it
Taylor's wife I don't understand what's
so great about this
life somebody explained that to me I
think with with somebody like Taylor
Swift is that like when she had first
come on the scene people like her Justin
Bieber right
the age group that we're [__] with
their music were pretty similar in age
you know so they were like pre-teens the
teens that were [__] with it and then
as they got older and the music sort of
evolved they stayed on you know stayed
with them and they grew with them yeah
they grew with them and so like I think
it's because they're able to relate to
the things that they were singing about
or talking about in their music whereas
for us it's we're so far removed from it
it's like yo that [__] is stupid as [__]
like not to say that you know it's
outright stupid but like where we are in
life that what we find important in
problems versus like let's say a
teenager or preteen right it's gonna be
it's like trivial to us because we've
already been there done that we got more
important things to worry about but
that's just the progression of life
right so like for them that's still real
like the the what they're talking about
like the heartaches of you know losing
your boyfriend or girlfriend at that you
know Puppy Love Stage and we're looking
at like come on man you don't know [__]
about love yet you know it's just like
when I look at Taylor Swift
um
she's had very huge hits in like I've
it's even stuck in my head but her
fandom to me never equated to her Talent
right and this isn't by the way yeah
Swifty plans I'm not saying she's not
talented she's very [__] talented she
makes like a good music yeah I just I I
guess if I were to explain to explain it
it's like I don't understand the fandom
behind it like the level I get that she
should be famous yeah but she's like
excelling like it's getting to the point
where they're going Taylor Swift or
Beyonce oh no no no no no no no no no
yeah no I mean I'm just saying no like
she's she's not on the level of a
Beyonce she has a lot more to do and
accomplish I feel like before she gets
there yeah and so people are saying like
the argument now is yeah you do like
Taylor Swift has surpassed Beyonce and
I'm like I I don't really see that and
by the way if you ask me if I'm a huge
Beyonce fan yeah no I think she's a
she's a pop she's a popular cultural
icon right right right but I wouldn't be
able to like if I hear Beyonce stop I'm
not like ah [__] you know I'm just like
oh that's Beyonce yeah it's like to me
Beyonce is Iconic like Missy Elliott
like if somebody told me I'm like oh
Missy Elliott is dope but they're like
yo why don't you rap like three of her
songs I wouldn't be able to but I know
it's an artist she's really [__] dope
yeah same thing with Beyonce but I don't
see Taylor Swift matching up to
Beyonce's like stature and especially in
terms of like what they've done yeah in
terms of accolades I'm speaking from
like an Accolade standpoint but I mean
at the same time I feel like people who
are fans of Taylor Swift can also easily
make an argument for her belonging up
there just in the sheer number of like
let's say hits yeah hits yeah yeah plays
Awards right and and look like you said
she's talented in her own right she
could write her own song she could play
instruments you know I think she's dope
yeah yeah but I I I I I also get where
you're coming from is that I think as a
you know almost 40 year old person I
look at her and I just I don't get it
hey somebody hey somebody who's a
[__] swify fan like you guys write
down what makes you love her so much
like I understand why people like her I
think she makes great music I think
she's a she's an icon all this other
stuff but they're oh even this people
are comparing them [__] like her
fandom and what she's done in the space
and you know her concerts and everything
like she's like Michael Jackson oh like
this this is the conversation
I strongly disagree on that like did you
touch kids I don't think so
I'm [__] kidding I'm [__] kidding
I still don't believe Michael did it by
the way it was allegedly it was
allegedly it was never proven but yeah I
mean yeah come on man
come on now but yeah no I that's I don't
know man I don't know I I look at her
and and look at kind of like
um her counterpart in terms of like a
guy pop singer would be like a Justin
Bieber right his fandom is crazy too and
they're hardcore and even though he
doesn't regularly put out music and he's
had these kind of controversies
throughout his his life the fandom is
still strong and Alive you know
um I see like when we talk about
um just go back to that topic about age
like I
I kind of
I'm seeing maybe not so much in like the
way that we look or anything else in our
age but like I said kind of where we
prioritize what's important and what's
not I one of the things that I get
really sad about
it's what I go on Instagram and I see
our friends who are getting older and
they're trying so hard to hold on to
their youth like they're it's it
literally hurts me yeah to watch them
try to be young and as if getting older
is the worst thing on Earth you know
what I mean and I see it a lot in
guys who kind of I knew that were the
definition of fuckboy before fuckboy was
coined the term right and they're trying
to hold on to the [__] boys trying to
be a [__] boy and you're 45 bro like
it's you can't do it it's not possible
your grades are in yeah that's just sad
it's even worse when when they are
married with kids and they're still
trying to be on that [__] it's the worst
man like I see them and it's funny too
I'm kind of [__] up because like I'll
I'll write like a [__] mean they
always delete my comments which is so
dumb right I [__] hate when they do
that
they're like chill bro chill yeah let me
be me let me do me so a friend of mine
um recently and you know he's been doing
this for quite a while now and everybody
knows it's about him and once again we
don't say names on the podcast and I'm
not gonna give you an Instagram handle
but I really wanted but he he started
recently using um bruh b-r-u-h right
this guy's like 46.
so he's not really like a friend he's
like a young right and you could tell he
literally just learned this word because
he uses it all the time now
you're right like in his captions like
you'll without fail C bruh put somewhere
in it yeah even when the context doesn't
allow for it and so I wrote on the
comment I'm like you literally learned
that word yesterday that you can't stop
using it you old ass [__] right and
then he deletes the comment immediately
and so I just kept reposting a different
version of that joke yeah because I
thought oh maybe something happened you
know so I just kept posting making fun
of him and it kept disappearing it's
like damn I was like are you deleting my
[__] comment yeah right yeah he goes
now quit [__] outing me out like that
dog I'm like well so you know it's true
then stop [__] doing this yeah but
he's becoming that guy too where
as you guys will get older you'll see
these type of friends where they just
refuse to Age and what I mean by that
age not in terms of your activity like
the youthfulness in you as a human being
but they want to be a part of a culture
that doesn't apply to them anymore right
the youth culture and so for us he's
kind of getting like weeded out yeah and
he's not really that close to me so in
that friend group he's getting weeded
out now where these friends are having
kids
um they're you know financially really
stable they're doing other things yeah
and because he can't relate to them
anymore he's now that 46 year old that
hangs out with 20 year olds is he is he
single still
he has a he has a girlfriend I think I'm
not sure if it's still together okay but
he's now that old guy that hangs out
with the young group and it's just like
watching it makes it hurts me I don't
know how the [__] you could be 46 and
hang out with a bunch of 20 year olds
what do you talk about yeah what do you
do is is my because look
going back to like the Big Bear trip
right like symptom of our age is look
how early we slept you know hey nobody
10 30 baby let's go nobody is up you
know raging till three four five in the
morning right or just not even raging
but just chilling even right
um but me and Ed we were actually
talking about this uh up in Big Bear too
is that like
where we're at now when you're single
without let's say a wife and a kid or
even kids
um what does your social life look like
you know because one we don't have the
same type of energy that we used to have
two we're not interested in doing the
[__] that we used to do in our 20s and
let's say even our early 30s right and
three is finding
um I guess the time for it too you know
and not to mention this is coming off
the heels of like the pandemic where we
kind of had a hard stop on social life
yet people at our age we were kind of in
that transition of going from like oh
we're going out every weekend to oh
we're not going out as much to oh we're
only seeing each other once like every
few months but then all of a sudden that
just became boom now nobody's seen
anybody for like a year or two yeah yeah
yeah and then we come out of it and then
it's like okay so what does social life
look like now you know and then like for
me most of my homies they're all married
with kids at least one kid if not two or
three even yeah
so
when we hang out it's in a some sort of
like hit event like like a birthday or
yeah
so for me like my social life I'm always
questioning like what do I do at this
age and like even if I want to do
something most times I'm like so tired
from like distress and and like you know
just a day-to-day [__] with secret
society that I don't even want to go out
I just want to chill and do nothing you
know on the other side too there are
friends who
they have the kid they are a lot older
right but they don't re they don't
they're not very cognizant of the fact
that once you had a child then you got
married your life has now changed yes
and so they they want to be a part of
your non-kid life but they don't know
how to right yeah so I had you know I'm
in that age now where my friends are now
having kids and so you know I'll go do
things and they go oh let's go do some
[__] together too yeah and they're like
okay like oh can like my wife and kids
come I'm like you're not coming
and they're like oh why not I'm like
this is not a wife and kids type of trip
I hate when people impose that man like
it's it's it's like equivalent to like
when we were younger and then it's like
homie strip yeah it's like yo can I
bring my girl no she's like bro we're
talking about a homies trip what in that
made you thought it's cool to bring your
girl you know that's what it is it's
really that version is so now they're
like oh oh they're just gonna be chill
it's like no no no no you don't
understand you're not coming like this
is not it's not because we don't want
you there you are now in a different
stage in your life and you have to
accept it right if in fact that it's a
family trip and then you want me to come
along with some other friends then yeah
because now we're on your schedule right
right because we're on your scheduled
family time so now it's like Uncle David
and whatever whatnot but the moment you
decided to have a kid you have to
understand this is your life now right
you're not going to be able to do the
stuff that we do so for example like
um this is pertaining to this trip but
it's happened multiple times and I'm
pretty sure anybody else out there who's
around our age whether in their late 20s
or early 30s have probably experienced
this where we're like hey let's all go
get dinner you know
and catch up and they go cool let's go
do that
they go oh
um can we find a place where kids are uh
where we can go with kids yeah more
kid-friendly no yeah we're not we're
absolutely not going to do that like
we'll do it on your Accord if it's what
if it's your event like this is our
event we're gonna go to a bar we're
gonna drink and we're gonna get some
dope ass food yeah I'm not gonna go on
to a place where I'm gonna get [__]
dino nuggets yeah you know yeah and it
hurts them a little bit yeah they're
like oh come on say no no
eight of us aren't going to change our
schedule for you you have to accept the
life that you made for yourself that's
on them though they got to be aware of
that yeah you know what I mean like you
can't impose your like your needs you
can't expect the majority to come and
accommodate you because you don't want
fomo you know what I mean like come on
man you got to be aware like okay I got
kids I got a wife uh these are all guys
who are just going out themselves okay
that doesn't fit that doesn't match that
environment so I'll see you next time
when I was in Hawaii uh the last time
there was a friend of mine who was there
too with this family he has like three
kids as all let's meet up and kick
inside let's go get some drinks or
whatever and I'm like you have three
kids how the [__] are you gonna how the
[__] are you gonna do this yeah but we
ended up not meeting up and then you
know for him you know it was like it
wasn't an awkward conversation but you
know these are like friends from like
Sacramento so I could talk about what I
want I'm like Hey listen man like you
you can't you're not going to be able to
kick it with me he's like no I'll just
tell my wife I'm like there's no way
you're gonna leave your wife with three
[__] kids impossible like I already
know this but he misses these moments
and he wants to have it you know with me
he's like oh let's go drain we'll go out
to a beach and just chill and we'll
catch up I'm like did you even ask your
wife if if this is even possible because
he'll be cool with it I was like get
back to me yeah it's not gonna happen
like of course it's not gonna happen
like also you would be an [__] to
leave your wife with three [__] kids
yeah like you're not gonna do that no I
mean you know it's like those uh type of
situations are far and few like you know
my my homies who are married with kids
like if I don't know sometimes we're
hanging out whatever they'll try to come
out here and there but like I said it's
so far and few and there's a trade-off
right sometimes like the wife will have
a night out with her friends and you
know the the husband will watch the kids
put them down whatever and then vice
versa right the the husband will go out
for a night out and the wife will you
know watch the kid but like that's not
something that's happening even like
once a month it's like once maybe every
few months or you know and so you gotta
understand that like that that is your
life now that is part of the
responsibility of becoming a parent a
responsible parent and a responsible
spouse you know you can't just enter
that chapter of your life and still do
the things the same way I think some
people have a little bit harder time
adapting and understanding that you know
um yeah that's the that's that weird
thing where like that I've dealt with
more of the guys not understanding their
new life now and then wanting to be a
part of everything else that we do yeah
so it's like nah we don't have kids yet
so if you do want to come apart we're
not we can't mold our schedule and
lifestyle to you yeah like when I go and
visit you and your family I'm on your
time and you're exactly the way you do
things exactly so if we're let's say we
all go to this big bear trip and there's
a friend is like okay I bring my two
kids I will punt your kids out into the
[__] Big Bear Lake no like I love
your kids yeah they're not coming yeah
you know what I'm saying yeah like it's
just I I don't want to deal with kids
screaming I don't want to be Uncle David
right now I want to [__] do my own
thing you know what I'm saying yeah and
you know again it's not like the
transition just happened like if you've
been in that chapter of your life for a
number of years you got to understand
like it's a different territory now
because it reminds me of like I remember
um a trip that we coincidentally took to
Big Bear with some of my homies and then
like it was just when when uh one of my
homies had like this first kid and he
was the first one yeah yeah and then so
like you know you brought the kid
because it was like girlfriends and
wives whatever
and I remember like you know even at
that age we were still kind of like
going ham with deep into the night of
course but then it was different now
like once it once the kid went down and
then we started getting loud and Rowdy
he's like hey keep it down you know like
the kid's sleeping and I remember
thinking like damn this is what it's
gonna be now yeah you know every year
that passes by this is going to become
more and more this group is going to get
smaller and smaller because they're just
not going to be available to like make
the trip uh but yeah like that's where
we are that's where we are now man
that's that's life you know and that
stuff happens too like I've definitely
kicked it with like Bart Geo my friend
Anna and Jeremy and when they bring the
kids we have to be a little more quiet
and we've learned but we've set the
expectation of this as like a family kid
trip you know and so those things are
okay right where I'm like okay and it's
weird too right so we're like okay we're
quiet we're chilling it's all kid time
and then you can see them when they put
the kids to bed at eight they're like oh
thank [__] God you know yeah it's
relief it's relief it's like eight to
like one yeah I'm kicking into doing
whatever yeah and then now too they have
like these white noise machines so we
get a little louder it's like the white
noise machine in the room they're like
finally [__] thank God and they get
to relax joke around first and do the
things that they normally do yeah and
you see the Freedom Light Up In Their
Eyes a little bit which is kind of dope
and you know you know if and when I have
a kid
if or when I have a kid is like I
understand it's going to be hard for me
to step away from my kid because you
know you're going to be worried about
them they're always going to be on your
mind but I'll tell you this though when
I need the space they're going to
Grandma and Grandpa's like get the [__]
out of my [__] site but that's like
such a huge luxury to even have 100 yeah
and like you know my parents hurt they
keep telling me to hurry up so that they
can watch my grandkids or their
grandkids while they're relatively young
and able and I'm like yeah you're right
like the the longer I wait that's gonna
become you know less likely that they're
going to be able to do that for me but
at the same time you know you gotta be
in your own pace you know what I mean
I'm not gonna rush to [__] get
married and have kids or whatever just
so that yeah yeah you know like we're in
a place right now where we're we are
very aware of these very specific time
stamps in our lives right so now when I
look at these photos and I can go back
to when we were at the apartment in
K-Town just kicking it there 24 [__]
seven going out in K-Town drinking
having fun eating and stuff and I look
at my life then and now I'm like oh [__]
like we all look a little different from
the different headspace for sure you
know yeah and yeah
genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by Mint mobile signing
your life away to Big Wireless providers
is kind of like being trapped on a
roller coaster crappy as hell sure it
looks fun at first they probably threw
in a free phone but now you can't get
off month after month of insane bills
and unexpected Thrills like overages and
surprise feasts if that sounds like your
current big Wireless plan is time to get
off the ride baby with mint mobile for a
limited time Wireless plans for mint
mobile are just 15 a month that's
unlimited talk text and data for just 15
a month mint mobile is the shiza my
friends 15 a month and I'm talking and
chatting away about my feelings to
everybody even all my friends who don't
want to listen to it I tell them about
my feelings they try to hang up but
guess what it's unlimited baby imma keep
on calling back I don't care all plans
come with unlimited talking text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network to get your
new Unlimited Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com genius15 that's
mintmobile.com genius15 cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com genius15
the other I mean dude we were you know
like going for [__] walks like like
old people that and we everybody enjoyed
it you know it's like we can't
like oh [__] the weather's not we should
go for a walk you know we go for a walk
come across
we're driving this boat like this
pontoon boat every time he saw a [__]
family this guy like the [__]
perverted neighbor
and I'm like bro you look like a creep
hey man I'm just being friendly we were
talking about that like all right we
were actually talking about this on the
trip and I was saying how much it pisses
me off when you know I being in LA and
you're just trying to be a decent human
being and you say hello to people you
wave at them or just you know
acknowledge them and they just [__]
stare at you they don't reciprocate and
like being in a place like that I know
people are a little bit more friendlier
so I know like yeah if I say hello to
somebody they'll reciprocate and hey man
I had people waving at me you know yeah
the funniest [__] was remember when that
dude was like um you know he saw a
relatively young guy and then so he was
like this and then gave me the piece and
then I waved like they said
he changes pieces
that [__] was hilarious but there's
there's people with so much money out
there it's unreal when we were on the
boat yeah yeah and just go and buy these
Mansions By The Lakeside right like
five-story [__] you know like three
thousand four thousand square feet
Mansions ridiculous I just want to know
what these [__] people do man it's
like what the [__] are you doing for a
living that allows you to live in a 4
000 square foot mansion bro I bet you
that's not even where they live though
not just a rental or let yeah not even
maybe a rental but yeah vacation home
dude because I want to know what it's
like to rent out one of those spots yeah
you know but I have to deal with 50
other people because it's too expensive
exactly
like no matter how much money I make I
don't care to spend things on like
luxury like like that right if it's
gonna cost me for a vacation just to
stay at a place two thousand dollars a
night
I'm not gonna go on my deathbed
wondering what that was like like I'm
not gonna Wonder yeah yeah this doesn't
matter you're right like I refuse I
still look at Honda Elements every time
I drive by and I'm like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you like that it's great but yeah I mean
look man it's it you know even though a
lot has changed I feel like the great
thing is is that like
because look man even your brother I
hadn't seen John in like five or six
years straight up since like he went to
SD you know because at least three years
because kovid right and then I hadn't
seen him before that either but then
like we see each other and you know the
the Rapport and the rhythm's still there
it's like we haven't missed the beat
yeah it's not like oh we haven't seen
each other in like five six years and so
we got to remember what this Dynamic was
like it's like it's still there and it's
adjusted to like where we are in life
now you know yeah I mean yeah like I
went back to some of the older stuff
like you know sometimes people ask like
how come you don't do sketches in this
anymore like I had a lot more time when
I was younger and energy
yeah
I didn't sleep at all I only started
sleeping in the last like four years
yeah and what I mean by that is I slept
on average two to three hours a night
for damn near 10 years yeah it was like
I'm not even exaggerating it was
literally two to three hours I would
sleep at maybe I don't know 4 AM
wake up at like seven or eight go up do
stuff and maybe take another nap for
like an hour 30 minutes in between the
day and it was like that forever yeah
just writing sketches
um doing stupid [__] traveling doing
whatever and then I just can't imagine
myself doing that now and I'm pretty
sure it wasn't healthy for me then so it
sure wasn't now I prioritize like rest
and sleep a lot and I think a lot of
people are just being smarter about it I
think during you know in our age group
there wasn't as much accessible
knowledge that this generation has now
even if it was like like 10 years ago
that 10 years because of like how much
technology has advanced and how
accessible like knowledge and
information is now you guys can make
healthier and smarter choices that we
didn't really know about but they don't
I think there's a lot more health
conscious people our age yeah you know
in a younger generation now right so now
they they get to listen to other
scientists that do podcasts or whatever
that talk about the importance of sleep
about health
people obviously we have an issue in the
states with unhealthy people and healthy
diets or whatever but the knowledge is
there and I see a lot of younger people
that prioritize their health yeah they
they have a very specific regimen and
I'll give you a great example when I was
in high school
when it came to
um like physical science like in terms
of weight training you guys have no idea
how many stupid [__] that we did that
was taught to us by our coaches true
right like there was no you know there
wasn't days for maximal effort there
wasn't times for when you would like
progressively overload on your waist we
would just jump [__] weights I tore
my um my chest benching because I jumped
from trying to bench um it was uh what
was it two plates and a 25 I don't know
how much that is that was 45 90 225
until 275 yeah that was my bench right
and I was trying to max out at 275. well
I did that adding the 225s jumping from
225 to adding to 25. like you would
never do that now and our on our weight
coach was like just try it out and you
would never see people do that well now
you're a lot smarter you progressively
overload that stuff you'll add five
pounds here 10 pounds here or whatever
and I [__] tore my chest like my
squat form was [__] terrible I
thought like my max squat when I was 18
years old was was 425. I guarantee you I
wasn't even doing a full squat I was
probably the death wasn't there and I
just pushed it back up and I said my Max
was 420. yeah yeah absolutely not most
likely it was probably around like the
mid 300s and like improper form and
everything yeah I probably would have
pushed steps like 350 at most right when
I was 18. so like the amount of
knowledge that young people have it's
it's way different so for us like I
didn't know how detrimental uh not
sleeping was to your brain yeah I had no
[__] idea and then when I started
reading things I'm like okay I need to
prioritize sleep which is why I started
smoking
and I don't like weed like uh during the
daytime when I need to have a
conversation yeah because it actually
irritates me that I can't be cognizant
of what's Happening like one of our
friends that was at the trip
he started uh he went through uh like a
pretty messy like a messy divorce and
then
I remember the day that he came over to
a mutual friend's house and he was like
talking about what's happening and what
he felt well he gave me a hit of his
[__] vape and by the way I don't
smoke hardcore [__] I literally smoke to
sleep it's medicinal for me yeah so he
gives me ahead of it I don't know how
strong weed is now my memory of weed is
when we were in high school you would
get like ditch like the the strongest
[__] back in the day was like [__] uh
like OG Kush you know whatever that type
of [__] right I don't even remember the
names anymore but nowadays they put
[__] Keith powder on top of it the
[__] sap the crystals all this other
[__] they got crazy names whatever the
[__] he gave me I smoked that [__] he's
like pouring out his heart to me and the
only thing I could I didn't hear any of
it all I would do was like I was like
stare at his nose and then pretend like
you care yes it'll just be normal just
be normal because I did he talked to me
like 30 minutes I don't remember a damn
thing yeah and all I kept was saying was
like damn that sucks man man I feel
sweet oh [__] Bro here's life and I just
kept repeating the same things because
it was so [__] harsh I don't know
what the [__] you guys smoke now it's
crazy it is crazy it's just like we were
talking about before we started this man
I was saying you know one hit can make
it an ordeal you know what I mean like
if you don't know what you're smoking it
can become an ordeal real quick real
fast the way I just you just end up in
another [__] Universe yeah so when we
were at Big Bear I you know they brought
they they brought some [__] to smoke and
it was like towards the end of the night
I took a couple of hits and I started
feeling a little drowsy but I was like
you know what I'm just gonna take a hot
shower and I'll come back out we'll
finish this movie all I remember was
taking a shower laying on my bed to
charge my phone and the next thing I
woke up it was boring
I was in the kitchen and then this one
walks out in the morning and I was like
yo and he's like dude what happened
well how is it morning right now I had
the craziest [__] dream too
it felt so [__] real it was it was
nuts so yeah with Paul yeah I had a
dream that our buddy Paul Paul came if
you guys know I did music with him Paul
owed a lot of money to these to this to
the Triads right and how why he owed him
a lot of money wasn't because he
borrowed money or because he was
gambling it was because he started a
business selling fake shoes right like
replicas and it was taking money from
their businesses
so he was like killing their business
and Paul was making a killing off of it
yeah so
this book is [__] kidnapped and
they're like literally beating the [__]
out of him right and it turns out one of
the dudes that had a deal with Paul was
a homie of mine right so I came in there
I found out where he was I came through
you know I dapped them up or whatever I
was like Hey listen like you can't
[__] kill him he's a friend of mine
yeah and he's like laughing he's like
okay cool he was like all right well
we can't just let him [__] go like we
don't our business is [__] because of
him yeah and this is feels so [__]
real to me like I couldn't even discern
that it was a dream even when I woke up
because it's still high while you're
doing this and so he goes okay well
we're gonna let him go and so they kind
of untime and then Paul's like [__]
balling because you know he's my married
man he's worried about his wife or
whatever yeah I was like hey I called
his wife I was like look Paul's fine
we're dealing with this he goes okay
well he owes us 10 mil now
within like the next couple of weeks
you're gonna be back here I'm gonna
[__] kill him yeah and he go and they
say to me it's like well and then you
now have a fee too and I'm like what the
[__] is going on yeah and so but my
field was very nominal it's like 10 G's
okay I don't know why 10 000. is this
taxi because you're there yeah you know
so I pay him the 10 G's yeah and I see
Paul and we take him outside his day
time now and Paul's sitting on the side
of the stairs and he's [__] bawling
because he's like what's gonna happen
about my wife and I was like Hey listen
this is what you got to do you just got
to get the [__] out the country right
because most likely they're not going to
find you or whatever he goes well if I
leave the [__] my family they'll know
where my family lives and my wife is and
he's like distressed and I'm like I
don't know what to [__] tell you I
can't help you out like the best thing I
could do is you know save your life and
make sure that you're not dead because I
happen to know the dude and then the guy
like Paul is bawling out of his [__]
mind and I'm like you gotta bounce so
I'm trying to drag him and like get him
to an airport just to buy a ticket to
leave the country then I wake up yeah
that's all I wake up
[Laughter]
oh man that's so funny I'm a good friend
though huh even in my dreams I'm down as
[__] yeah
yeah we hung out with Paul uh a week
before I know man this [__]
posted a picture I said bro thanks for
the invite man what the [__] well I
didn't know he was there for a wedding
yeah and I didn't know because we met up
I met up um I won't say her name but
another mutual friend you know Paul's
best friend yeah the girl yeah so I
thought she was oh actually Paul is in
town too I was like what the [__] yeah
we're actually here for a wedding and
she goes I didn't put two and two
together yeah and then I think Z knew so
it was Z and John yeah they were all
hanging out yeah
and so I I wrapped up dinner with with
her and then we just met up at the hotel
and that was it yeah but we were dude we
were out to like [__] like two or
three back in the day yeah I woke up
[__] up it was so bad I'm like we used
to do this [__] every night yeah and I
can't and it it made me feel like I had
flashbacks of old time K-Town and I just
can't imagine myself doing this every
night yeah bro it's different man it's
different even if you're not doing an
activity and you just going out and just
hanging out it's taxing man it's taxing
and that's coming from somebody like me
was a night owl I'm a [__] night out
but there's a difference between a night
owl and just like relaxing versus a
night owl and going out and doing
something and chilling you know
100 like when I woke up the next day
because we you know Paul drinks a lot
like Paul can drink anybody of the human
garbage can was his nickname this bull
would eat the same amount as me drink
more than me yeah but still have a
six-pack I know and she was upsetting
and then he would sober up in like two
hours and then wants to do it all over
again
what do you mean man the next day I woke
up like I think at 12 which is the
latest I've woken up in years just
hurting every cell in my body was aching
yeah and then you know Paul mentioned
he's like good to see you bro I'm like
you seem fine
dying my insides are [__] like my head
is pounding everything is bad dude did
you get tossed up or like where you just
get got a good Buzz going well
ah pretty tossed out and I sobered up
being that a drive yeah yeah but even
then the after effects were still there
it's lingering it's still lingual
because I was sober when I drove because
I stopped drinking like at least two two
hours before before I left yeah so I was
fine I was sober but then the next
morning aching yeah right I was like how
the [__] is this possible dude I think I
think the quintessential like moment of
describing how Paul uh eats and drinks
is that like uh that one time when it
was his birthday and this guy got
[__] smashed we went to McDonald's at
like four in the morning 24 hours
yeah exactly right on Vermont you know
and this like we have to help this guy
in because he can't [__] like walk
properly eats like three [__] value
meals you know sober's up is like let's
keep drinking it walks out completely
fine like yo what the [__] is wrong with
you bro he's not human yeah like how
does that happen now you guys gotta
understand we're not at McDonald's for
like five hours we're just there for
like I don't know an hour tops right
he [__] yeah runs through like three
[__] meals talks completely normally
walks out completely normally like let's
keep let's go back and keep drinking if
I could give you guys like a little
glimpse of what we used to do like there
was a spot it closed down now and if
you're like a K-Town head you would know
about the spot called Pipers like Pipers
was like the late last spot open 24 7
and then it started at 24 7 then they
started closing around like two yeah
um but either way it was like the last
minute spot that you could always go to
aside from like the late night fuss
spots and everything else like K-Town
before covid was popping till six seven
a.m in the morning oh yeah you could
find like the after hour spots which
were underground you know it was super
fun so Pipers used to have this thing
called their kimchi carbonara
and the pipersburg the Pipers burger
with that parmesan crust on the bread
parmesan crust and they had like I think
it was sourdough yeah it was it was
sourdough white bread slice and it was a
burger with their Piper Special Sauce
yeah and a few other things so good I
used to eat the kimchi carbonara the
Pipers burger and the fries and a Diet
Coke yeah that was like my whole meal
that's that's already after I had dinner
breakfast and lunch this is the late
night snack the late night snack was at
least 3 000 calories for sure and this
is why I got really [__] fat so when
I came from so Sacramento and Sacramento
does have good food but it's hard to
compare what that food is like when you
can go to La La is just it's just more
competitive so people have to make
better food for sure that's just um you
know an aftermath of living in a a very
impacted Metropolitan City yeah so when
I came to La I was like dude this food
is [__] nuts here it's delicious I
couldn't stop eating I had Korean
barbecue every [__] all you can eat
you know all you can eat yeah yeah I
used to go eat Korean barbecue 24 7. all
you can eat all the time and then at
night we would go eat at Pipers so Paul
would eat the same food as meat exactly
and then he wouldn't still be fit and
I'm gradually getting fatter and fatter
and fatter and I had no [__] idea
yeah now when I came to La I was already
pretty big I was heavier than I am now
right which I was like probably like 2
30. yeah well I went from 2 30 like 290
eventually oh [__] and your max your
highest is like 290 almost 300 pounds
yeah very [__] close that was 290
pounds and so when I started making that
switch to healthier food yeah it was
really hard I remember I remember I was
just like eating vegetables yeah like
like eating out would be would be like
we go to like California fish grills you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dude our
buddy Z yeah and if you've seen Z on our
podcast I have the music with him too he
went from like I think at the time he
was like 180 and then he went down to
like 145. yeah and he had a six pack
which is crazy but he was so serious
about the way he was losing weight we
would go out to Korean barbecue and he
brought out a portable scale yeah that
was that used to piss me off man I'm
like put that [__] away bro like come on
dude you could just [__] do like
roughly you don't gotta sit there
weighing each [__] you know wait out
every piece of meat and whatever went
into his mouth and mind you his results
were [__] amazing yeah it was but I
was like that's a little too much man
it's not gonna [__] make or break
anything you know but guess what
happened this whole how to taste the
[__] carbs again [__] blew up
again no it's the pandemic it was the
pandemic you know like once the pandemic
hit he wasn't able to work out it
started getting complacent lazy you know
just eating whatever yeah got married
yeah exactly you know so now he's like
I'm happy
I'll tell you this though I do like
watching you meet again
because he's the type of dude who really
enjoys the food yeah it makes me want to
eat yeah yeah yeah
it's like oh we got the old z-back I
know no no you're exactly right though
like when he was on that fit tip going
out to eat with him wasn't enjoyable
because he's like so conscious about
every little thing I'm like dude just
enjoy the meal man you're out just relax
a little bit put that stupid [__] away
you're not a [__] drug dealer he's
not Wayne grams put that [__] away and
just enjoy I was like dude this is a
relatively healthy meal that you're
eating right now yeah it's a chicken
breast with salad you know like just
enjoy it the hard part is is because me
and z are the way that we eat we're very
we're pretty much twins we're both
degenerated it's either
there's no in between yeah there is
either you control what you eat or you
go to the depths of hell like I like I
blink out sometimes when I eat food and
like even at the Big Bear trip right dog
we were eating anything and everything
inside and I didn't make healthy food
either yeah like I did the well the
tacos were pretty healthy yeah it's
actually yeah tacos are healthy yeah I
did like um carne asada tacos with
Cotija cheese like roasted salsa we I
did the the Spanish
um chistora uh sausages
super [__] good breakfast now at the
point at night I probably could have
eaten three tacos that was cool I ate
I ate tacos that night holy [__] I
didn't know you yeah I ate tacos
actually you know what that's why those
[__] there was no more uh burritos oh no
no that was the tacos the burritos how
many did you have in the morning oh I
only had half okay okay I had half and I
had but I had the chicken
yeah yeah the burritos though yeah like
that wasn't healthy at all oh yeah that
I would have to eat the chips the
[__] red velvet cookies oh those red
velvet cookies they were so [__] good
money we had like beef jerky after that
well Dan [__] brought like 10 bags of
sticks so I was like dude you're you're
here for one night bro like what are you
trying to do man we did some work on
those things though he was like just in
case and I was like all right you know
they got [__] blown it yeah it is
what it is dude but I definitely have a
problem with like portion control and
that's what me and Z have an issue with
yeah so it's like either we control it
to the T yeah because we can't
self-regulate you know those dogs that
don't know how to regulate their own
food like certain dogs they'll eat food
out of the bowl and when they're full
they'll stop right I'm not yeah I'm the
labrador that eats until they throw back
right because I don't know I don't know
when I'm full yeah I just know that I'm
enjoying what I'm doing even at that Big
Bear trip I wasn't feeling very good
because I haven't eaten like that in a
long time nobody was feeling good enough
I ate through the pain and I was like
God my stomach hurts yeah I don't have
to yeah I can't even do that for a
workout yeah I mean like if I work out I
go oh just power through no the Marius
knows like if I work out at home I'm
hitting the bag three minutes in second
round is three minutes I do a minute and
a half because I'm like you know what I
think I sweated a little bit and I
stopped and then I move on and I get no
results but it's hard for people who
have like an addiction towards food we
can't sell right regulate so I think
that's why Z had to do it to the T yeah
because if we give ourselves an inch we
go seven thousand miles yeah exactly but
it's the same thing with you too is that
like you know when it comes to food like
I associate you guys like unz with like
us just because you know me I don't eat
a lot but I enjoy eating you know in
general and I like trying things and so
like when I'm with you guys I like that
but then when you guys are very you know
health and diet conscious I'm like oh we
can't just go anywhere and just eat
anything it's possible yeah impossible
like if I stop by McDonald's if I tell
myself hey you what's this is like the
funniest [__] by the way so this is what
I [__] hate about Google Maps Google
Maps be [__] outing you out like
they'll because what happens is that
they always show you the place like if
you're going towards the direction that
you're going it'll show you the place
that you typically go to all the time
and say is this where you want to go so
we're driving back home right and I plug
my phone in yeah it says McDonald's
like
how often do you go to McDonald's where
the [__] GPS in your phone wow
it's a big girl that I always go to
I got so pissed at my phone I'm like yo
how the [__] are you gonna out me out
like that that's crazy I've never seen
that oh he was dying laughing how often
do you go well it's been so hot during
the summer I probably get like a saucer
from there every other day
that [__] pissed me off I was so [__]
mad that [__] was hella embarrassing
dude but speaking of McDonald's we were
talking about this [__] too it's like
[__] ten dollars now for value meals
great you can't call it a value meal
anymore there's no value in that so
before we went to uh Big Bear we went to
McDonald's to stop by yeah and I told
him I had that McDonald's in a long time
I lied well you got caught yeah
but we got uh two Filet-O-Fish meals and
then a double cheeseburger meal right
the the regular size not the large it
came out to 35 bucks God damn three
[__] value meals came out to 35 bucks
at McDonald's yeah that's unreal back in
the day not even back in the day this is
before pandemic yeah that would have
came out to like 22 bucks exactly bro
the like a McChicken is 2.99 now it's
three dollars that used to be 99 Cents
you know now granted okay I know
inflation and that was many years ago
but we're not that far removed from the
99 cent stays yeah this is only a
handful of years ago so if it was
sitting at like maybe I don't know 199
now 189 170 okay I get it 2.99 what the
[__] crazy three dollars for a McChicken
that Mash there's not even like chicken
chunks it's just [__] matching
chicken you know and there's guess what
hasn't changed though that's soft serve
though oh yeah delicious oh yeah thank
God for the saucer yeah I I eat that so
often because my soft shell company went
down
for the value McDonald's soft serve is
great like is it artisanal but no it's
that you know powder mix whatever but
it's good but even the soft serve they
used to be like 79 cents 89 cents how
much is in that like bucket that night
it's a dollar something okay yeah
I don't know it actually goes away in
two seconds it's almost comical it's
classic though I mean the the worst
thing for me is that like whenever I'm
I'm craving um a soft serve while like
passing by McDonald's I'll pull in and
they won't ever [__] have it because
the machine's down you know not the one
that I go to you got a good one they
know me yeah it's almost weird like I
kind of get a little embarrassed yeah
when I show up like how you doing man
I'm like don't don't talk to me like
your friends I'm just here for the song
don't get familiar bro yeah just give me
about what I ordered like how's the
family hey [__] you man just give me my
[__] saucer dogs see you're the
you're the problem bro you're the type
of guys who I'm saying hello to I didn't
want to reciprocate I don't want it yeah
don't [__] it like the people behind you
are like how often does he come here new
haircut
this episode of The Genius brain podcast
you can catch Junior's brain every
Sundays at 12 p.m uh if you guys are a
sneaker head out there and I said that
you're terribly dressed don't take that
too personally because if it is you just
fix it all right just stop spending all
the money on your [__] shoes get a
[__] haircut bathe yourself do
something about that look presentable
yeah uh you could catch Ed at Ed too and
the secret society
s-e-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y we are dropping a
new line very soon you'll see that in
another podcast
um but uh do you explain every Sundays
at 12 p.m and we'll see you all next
time peace
foreign
[Music]